germany has started its journey back to
a sort of normal life but it is slow
progress
here in dusseldorf schools will open for
a couple of year groups
limited numbers temperature checks
disinfected rooms multiplied by 3 over
13.
at this international school they've
already welcomed back a handful of
students
but they know the next step will be much
more demanding
we've set up the social distancing we've
kept the two meters not one and a half
meters two meters
separation and we have fixed all of the
signs
to reinforce the social distancing it's
going to be hugely challenging for
children coming back
after months of not seeing their
their peers except virtually but i think
we will manage it
some students have already said they
won't be coming in others
will return keen to use school as a
touchstone to regular life
we have to try to have some kind of
formality
and try to kind of support the economy
so it's really finding a midway between
all opinions and
making sure that we do our best to not
spread it anymore
for parents at least for the parents of
children returning to the classroom
this also feels like a milestone in the
story of this virus
it's a huge impact of course for for the
well-being of the children
for a long time i mean for shorter time
they of course they're fine being home
but for a longer period of time
i think it's really important to get the
children back to school
germany has already eased restrictions
small shops are trading
playgrounds and museums will open
there's a hint here
of how life used to be so the schools
are going back
some of the shops are open and there are
plenty of people around if it
weren't for the masks you might think
that this was
life as normal but there are those who
think that germany has gone
too far too fast in loosening its
lockdown
change will vary between regions some
will ease rules
quicker than others here they think
they've got the balance
just about right we have declining
numbers and i believe it's important
because germany doesn't just consist of
students
but also economic and social structure
it's important we think of how we can
return
step by step to a normality but while
adhering to rules about hygiene
the fear is of the unknown of what will
happen in germany and beyond
when countries relax their rules virtual
classrooms
will be replaced by real ones many here
and across europe will be watching to
see what happens next
adam parsons sky news dusseldorf